What's our van name?
>> Vangooooogh.
>> That's my van.
Now I am left here.
It's good.
Okay, I'll catch you in Chicago.
[MUSIC]
>> Passport to Paris.
>> Oooh!
Wow!
>> We met with people in
big cities like Chicago,
including a labor union leader there to
learn about how they think about work.
It really spans the spectrum
from small all the way to large.
>> Taking Ubers to Uber.
>> This can be disorienting for some, but.
[MUSIC]
>> My God.
>> Awesome.
>> Very inspiring.
>> Whoo.
>> This is awesome.
[CROSSTALK]
>> Seeing Shinola.
[MUSIC]
>> China's much more than the Beijing
Olympics, much more than cheap exports,
much more than all the competitiveness
that you hear in the news.
[MUSIC]
>> The access that Stanford
gets you is unbelievable and
you see that first hand on a GST.
[MUSIC]
Axel Springer Plug and Play.
>> It could be an incubator.
>> An incubator,
Lufthansa's Innovation Hub.
>> Criteo.
>> Delivery Hero, which is a door dash of
In Europe, we went to Rocket internet.
[MUSIC]
>> A GSTs an adventure.
>> It's also packed.
>> But
it's a chance to go outside the bubble.
It's a bonding experience.
It's a lot of fun.
It's educational.
It's a touching time with your classmates.
>> It's transformational.
[MUSIC]